hey youtubers this is Charlie this is
gonna be my Game of Thrones telltale
gameplay I'm gonna upload at least two
of these first videos on this channel
and then I'll upload the rest to my
bonus channel so I'll have links to that
in the description I have a game channel
it's just called Charlie's dreams
so please enjoy overall there's about
two hours or so worth of gameplay per
episode
this is gonna be episode one so there'll
be like four or five videos of this I'll
just break it up into like 15 minute
chunks just remember too that it's all
taken from the end of season 3 to the
beginning of season 5
the great Jamie Lannister
Kings we sneeze by the men of the north
this is picking up like right at the end
of the red wedding or I think the red
wedding is like happening right now like
right at the end of season 3 itself you
know make sure it's spotless this time
forest it won't be happy with blood and
brains all over it go on it's only blood
now that the proper sword I love will
lock it myself someday I say that is a
friend and if we're being honest you
know Justice Breyer I will you'll see
you'll see I see a lordship after you
take your rightful place on the Iron
Throne captura name he was nowhere near
the Kingslayer at whispering wood he was
so drunk he barely made out of his tent
next I'll tell us he caught tearing to
it you think he's lying
no [ __ ] never lets the truth stand in
the way of a good story you captured the
Kings forest not before he dragged you
out for a across the battlefield on your
face you're questioning Lauren's honor
I'm questioning not a story this close
more far-fetched every time he tells it
it elites vote some wine go on it's your
job right thanks
thank you God I'll do it Laurens family
has faithfully served house Forrester
for centuries his honor is beyond
reproach house Tully is forever in his
debt they've never seen a field proud so
well
that's the day the Kingslayer dragged
for Noren across the bottom if he was
actually involved in the capturing of
Jaime Lannister then he really just
helped Catelyn Stark that's your girl
but these are none of these characters
were featured on the show
so like anyone you see in the game is
completely original to this game but
they do flow from the original source
material has been given the greatest
honor this isn't gonna end well for
anyone in this army iron from ice is
just this House's motto need you
Roderick is like the Robb Stark of this
house the Foresters house yes my lord is
most of the question on my mind for a
while what do you mean you served us
Forrester well for several years now but
I can't expect you to Squire forever
how shall I reward your loyalty what can
I offer you
you served me well let me fight for you
my lord no man would question that Lord
Forrester remember that when you don't
quit fall if your name is my Squire
you've erased those doubts entirely it
would be an honor to see you riding by
Roderick side in the vanguard tomorrow
not as a squire but as the equal of any
man who serves housefull I hope he
doesn't offer me a seat at the red
wedding your hard work has paid off
thank you Menard I promise I won't write
in front of Walder Frey but for now keep
this between us I wouldn't want the
other Squires to feel discouraged
yes my lord now God and find Roderick if
you can I will my lord thank you so I'm
using the mouse but you can actually use
your Xbox or ps4 controller with this on
the Steam version play this lawful good
the first time through
it's more wine
Just My Luck let em fetch his own wine
for once he's a drunk liar
and an arrogant prick you'd better watch
your tongue boy it could be much worse
Bowen Marsh about it nothing is worse
than your e see that's where you're
lucky low expectations
big [ __ ] trouble and slop well maybe I'd
think saddling his horse was the
greatest on there in the Seven Kingdoms
I suppose this beats pig farming but not
by much
this is a job for a pig farmer this rate
we'll never be more than this which is
nothing the lowest of the Lord I know
most of this game is supposed to take
place up in Deepwood Motte [ __ ] time
give it time
you'll get that that's where the
wolfswood is housed blubber actually
controls most of that
red wedding take your time
that does not look like a friendly
person he might be one of the phrase up
[ __ ] phrase nice night for a wedding
I've got tingly feelings don't expect me
to carry it for you so Garrett yeah I
think it's most platforms at least by
tomorrow and they're actually releasing
like an Android version of it so I guess
she'll be able to play it on mobile too
we need to get back right now just
quietly back aways just slink into the
night what's wrong with him
actually right now Arya Stark in the
houndour probably riding around in the
background somewhere
sorry Betty
I'm gonna make the hard call
that's a good question like if you could
save Robb Stark
or Arya Stark which one would you save
because you say Robb Stark
you might be able to marshal his army
the Arya Stark is a really important
character
whoa
shoot that one there we go this is what
happens when you use the mouse in the
keyboard for game designs for Xbox
controller
take that
well there Rob start died - did you see
hey he's got my lord there was nothing I
could do
placemarks Quine so in this alternate
timeline it starts the one that survives
boy quickly
[Music]
you [ __ ] traitor go my lord while
there's still time
seven hills
we have to keep moving milord how's it
going everybody
guard this with your life the gelatin
wrath but it belongs there's no time to
waste
I won't leave you Milan and you will
know I know coach you will Oh baby's not
gonna remember it for very long because
he looks like he's gonna die do you
understand you must swear tell only your
uncle Duncan the future of the house may
depend on there must always be a stark
in Winterfell if you guys actually watch
season for the the Bolton's we're
actually marching on Winterfell the last
time we saw them in season four so
season five there will be some more
Winterfell
achievement unlocked
I guess this is a prologue
they talked about it during season one
but the same company that did the intro
sequence for Rome on HBO did the intro
for this so if you really like like this
model look you should check out the rome
series I mean it it came and went a long
time ago but it was a really good TV
show thanks so much for watching this
part of the gameplay so I'm gonna upload
part two to my bonus channel now and
then every video after that to that game
Channel although every once in a while I
might stick one on this channel just for
fun
this actually was inspired by the card
game or I mean though the role-playing
game at the card game and you can click
on these links to get to the other
videos I'll try to upload everything by
the end of tonight I'll be streaming
again tonight too